[Music]
i love dicks
i love dicks
huge fans
love their wood dicks are the best i'm
pro-dick
i'm pro-dick
one action
welcome to pro dick's
is that the name of the show sounds like
a pro shop for dicks
welcome to pro dicks all right
we're gonna talk about some sanctions
i'm talking about some western sanctions
talk about some western sanctions talk
about some western sanctions is this
about the ukraine and russia so russian
oligarchy
a russian oligarch worth 13 billion
dollars
now cannot pay his cleaner because of
said western sanctions wait so he's like
broke broke
like all his bank accounts all his
finances are just frozen yeah that came
in right he should have got bitcoin dawg
so his name
is mikhail friedman fredman i don't know
if i'm pronounced right but anyways he
said he doesn't know how to live after
his wealth was stripped by western
sanctions this russian businessman
currently lives in the uk
and has a net worth of about 13.7
billion
wow
and while shells rained down on the
people in ukraine he has told people uh
in articles that his suffering after
copying sanctions for the european union
on february 28th uh and march 15 have
put him in such a place where he can't
pay his
home cleaners so he has to clean the
house by himself oh
he has to mop
i was like
i can't believe it i'm mopping
so i can't believe
for me
do you think he wished he had a smaller
house i used to be an old tycoon
[Laughter]
he did say we sincerely believed we are
such good friends of the western world
that we couldn't be punished
the 57 year old banking mandate
co-founded london investment firm letter
one and is a former board member of
russia's alpha bank can you imagine
trying to mop a ten thousand square foot
mansion he previously how do you wash an
airplane
it was like this is not enough
my house is too big he's using windex to
clean his plane
that's probably why all those uh chinese
ballers the minute they have money they
start sending it west huh yeah because
they already distrust their government
so like any time the government can
freeze my [ __ ] so to keep it liquid i'm
gonna buy homes in america i'm gonna set
up bank accounts in america have a kid
in america yeah that's smart
dang because of the sanctions he is he
is allowed to withdraw about 2 500
pounds a month which is technically more
than the average uh british person gets
in their salary after taxes 2 500
so aka um
yeah bubble it's like a spending
allowance because of the sanctions but a
billionaire with 3-4 grand a month
that's a huge good job because his bills
are probably in like the millions a
month and he also has to apply for a
special license in order to spend money
wow
not [ __ ] crazy they're getting
wrecked
it's hard for me to feel bad for a
billionaire but then um i'm also
wondering like why did they attack
the rich people of russia like do they
have some connections to the government
or did they have some involvement
because i'm just curious like
at least you know in the states if let's
say something happened and can you
imagine like them [ __ ] with bezels
and bill gates and all that stuff and
i'm like
isn't it just attacking all of the
people like the sanctions are on the
people
and so if you utilize like the banking
services
then whether you're poor or rich you
just get [ __ ] right
he says that uh he's um he hit out at
sanctions claiming that he doesn't even
have the power over putin or the
kremlin's decisions quote i've never
been in any state company or state
position
uh if the people who are in charge in
the eu believe that because of sanctions
i could approach mr putin and tell him
to stop the war and it will work then
i'm afraid we're all in big trouble this
guy's cool man yeah i get that i mean
he's a realist yeah yeah
can you imagine like let's say
the owner of like petco of russia or
some [ __ ] you know like he's like yeah i
i just sell [ __ ] doggy food
[Laughter]
america like uh
come on if you want the doghouse i give
to you but
this anxious man
i'm assuming those because they want him
to stop spending his money in ukraine
and russia i mean russia right and it's
all about the flow of money on how
russia is going to
build their military to continue
fighting because they get taxed yeah the
taxes and stuff that because right now
when they cough the oil they cut off all
the money going back into russia as well
all of it you know and all those
pipelines that flow into western europe
is like so russia as a
as an entity
will not have any more revenue coming in
yes
and it collapses their economy in
general but it's also going to collapse
western europe because most of their
energy
comes from russia so that's a huge it
was a conflict of interest too because
um
germany like you know
maybe 90 something percent of all their
oil and everything gases everything the
pipelines they all like connected to
russia does that incentivize germany to
want to fight america then because then
they're like if you're choking my
pipeline
you're now my enemy too well they're a
part of nato so like traditionally like
you know they're on the west right so
like they've always been on that side so
um
there's this there's this funny exchange
like when when trump was in uh office
uh back then maybe a lot of people
didn't get it but it's been going around
like on youtube and it's it's a clip of
him just talking [ __ ] to the german
chancellor and saying like like or like
the representative and he goes isn't it
a conflict of interest that you have a
pipeline with russia and like what if
something happens
and then it's like how are you part of
nato but at the same time all of your
energy comes from russia yeah and then
i'm like oh damn hmm i don't know
politics is weird but
yeah how would you navigate that you
know it's just crazy that like all the
things that were sound bites by trump
before that sounded [ __ ] crazy
now you're like oh damn each thing kind
of makes sense now holy [ __ ] yeah but
it's he's such an unlikable character
like that if you say anything that maybe
even sounds like you're supporting it
then all of a sudden you're like this
trump supporter and people hate you but
then like i'm like god damn dude i wish
it wasn't so
like one way or you gotta be against or
with or like
why don't you just flirt with the middle
and stop calling trump stop calling
donald mr donald ducks
mr donald trump you know what donald was
talking about how
just sounds so nice
donald because of donald duck because
even like you know like right now it
seems like putin's like this powerful
ass dude right but then before like the
video of going around is trump always
like pulling [ __ ] in yeah the
handshake yeah he's pulling everyone in
and then at the in those days when he's
saying crazy [ __ ] like this guy's a
[ __ ] bully but then now you're like
when there's an actual bully like a
right like uh yeah like um ascending
you're like oh that guy was kind of like
keeping people in check a little bit did
you see the compilation of of him not
getting handshakes i love it dude like
he's all like getting ready to shake
hands and then like the prime minister
of like france or whatever is like oh
putin not
or like even kim jong-un he's all like
showing putin like a map and [ __ ] and
then putin's just like pulls out his
hand and he just looks at his it's
hilarious just play this because it's
semi worth it they're scared putin's
gonna shoulder throat yeah yeah yeah
he's gonna judo toss him and then putin
just puts his hand back on his paw it's
like a lit it's like so funny i hope we
don't get none of the music's not gonna
fly that's right no we just make it
silent no no music but yeah
so
here we go here we go
oh he went back for twice
what about this one
[Music]
it's the origin of a villain bro yeah
and then when he reaches for the hand
and then he looks down at his hand for a
second and goes wow the internet always
wins he he saw this video and then he
started the war dude
it was the day after he started after
all yeah he was like all these [ __ ]
never shake my hand
i bet there's a sentiment of that though
right like he's trying to prove or
something to everybody that's why he's
like pressing so hard for this in a lot
of weird ways yeah
his back is against i will say it is
crazy seeing like videos of like uh
russians on their balconies and stuff
taking like rubles and just throwing it
out because it just means nothing now
what yeah you haven't seen those and you
got chinese people at the bottom
catching it
[Laughter]
have you heard about um they're not
allowed to go on facebook or like a lot
of these things are getting blocked now
yeah and then um there's actually
russian youtubers that they're vlogging
and all that and they're like i don't
know when it's gonna be gone so we're
living in a weird [ __ ] time now where
we can watch people
that you know are supposed to be our
enemies and we can see what's happening
out there and whatever
and it's kind of weird man like it's
like everyday people
are kind of like now we get to connect
better because we can see what's
happening and we can treat them as human
beings whereas in the past
i think as even as like as early as when
we were kids right it was easier for
nations to assemble people and and their
citizens and say
[ __ ] those guys those guys are the devil
yeah and we're here to murder all of
them right and then you only get the
propaganda that's given to you only
there's not no other perspective no
other voice there's no no seeing videos
of people you know protesting in front
of you know the kremlin and stuff like
that yeah and whatnot there's actually a
viral clip going around right now of a
russian instagram influencer and she's
like totally crying and stuff like that
because she's talking about how as an
instagram influencer that's her job
that's her life obviously people are
kind of like low-key shaming her and
giving her backlash though because like
i don't maybe people still don't fully
understand the concept of being a social
media influencer but she's definitely
just like
balling about how like instagram is now
closing so she like has is losing her
livelihood and her ability to do
everything that's scary
and that's just like that's real yeah
that's crazy and it's from war but it is
kind of funny that like it is my career
but i think it's hilarious
it is like a boohoo thing still
it's like i can see myself too like
crying my eyes out if all of youtube and
instagram disappears and i'm like [ __ ]
my livelihood but then also the comedy
kicks in and i'm like dude that's
hilarious
just still work out vladimir's pizza or
whatever vladimir speaks huge piece of
chain yeah
we're all gonna work out vladimir's
pizza
[Music]
you